here with more making money hosts
Charles Payne along with the founder of
the committee to unleash Prosperity
Stephen Moore
I guess Charles let me start with you
tonight do you agree with Larry's
analysis of this and isn't this a
billionaire bailout in the at the end of
the day
well you know I'm going to be less
diplomatic than Larry okay yeah the yeah
the answer is obviously ultimately when
Banks when banks have higher fees they
pass them on to their customers so we
know that that's what businesses do
um yeah this is a bailout this is a
bailout of really Silicon Valley itself
over the weekend Silicon Valley went on
the attack they stoked fear particularly
on social media that this is going to be
a chain of events and that people be
lined up across the country at Regional
banks that take their money out I went
to three banks on Saturday there wasn't
a line anywhere nobody was panicking so
here's the thing they were calling it an
extension event for Silicon Valley how
do we get here for 20 years Silicon
Valley has been able to take these
companies public that were exorbitantly
overvalued they made billions and
billions and billions of dollars they
bought the world's biggest Yachts they
built the biggest homes in the world and
from from the moment of covet when all
that extra money came out from the
Federal Reserve and then the federal
government Silicon Valley banked their
deposits when up 300 percent almost to
200 billion dollars the average Bank in
America their deposits went up 30
percent it was a good times so they had
all of this cash what did they do with
it they didn't lend it out and they
certainly never never lent it out to
regular folks no regular folks got this
money none okay so they decided to
invest it and they wanted to get yield
everyone's looking for yield these days
and so here's the thing and everyone's
got to listen to this when President
Biden comes out today and he starts to
say well I'm going to you know demonize
the banks I'm going to make sure that
these Banks don't do anything Reckless
well they bought bonds with it U.S bonds
with it there's no other uh investment
in the world they call it risk free the
problem though of course is because the
Federal Reserve has had to come in and
aggressively attacked inflation which by
the way went over the top with that
Biden uh two trillion dollars they've
Jay Pal's hands have been tied to a
degree and they've tried to battle
inflation and consequently last year
bonds had their first year ever the last
year the last 14 months 14 months in
anyone's lifetime it's amazing Steve
Moore how JP Morgan Peter Thiel other
smart people JP Morgan was writing about
this in November for crying out loud but
explain how it's Biden's economic
policies uh his energy policies that
cause record high inflation record high
inflation resulting in in this Bank uh
investing a ton of money in treasuries
ETC uh then all of a sudden people need
their money and they've got to cash it
out a massive loss isn't that a big
contributing factor here and how many
other banks around the country might be
doing this
yeah you know it's a complicated story
but in a lot of ways it's not so
complicated Sean uh you kind of did a
pretty good job of explaining and
connecting these dots first it starts
with trillions and trillions of dollars
of out of control spending then the
government has to borrow that money to
finance all these six trillion dollars
of additional spending Biden
um enacted then the next step is all
this money is flowing into the economy
and as you just correctly said that
additional money caused interest rates
to rise and inflation to rise and so now
the FED has to act and it has to raise
these interest rates to bring inflation
down and you've seen a big increase in
these uh in these interest rates over
the last three years and this has caused
big problems for banks I do think there
may be other Banks like I don't think
we're going to see a major Bank Run or
something like that I think people
should be feel feel fairly secure but
they're probably other Banks as you
mentioned that are in this situation I
don't but one other point that I feel
strongly about Sean all I've heard from
Biden over the last several weeks since
his budget came out we're gonna make the
rich pay their fair share we're going
after these rich people they're making
too much money Etc and who do you think
is going to benefit from and look I will
call it a bailout because I think it is
people with with um
deposits of less than 250 000 that's the
middle class right Sean they are
protected under current FDIC rules what
this is going to do is provide a bailout
for the people with you know millions
and millions of dollars of these in
accounts and gee I thought he was going
to Sock It To the rich and now he's
giving them a big bailout yeah
unbelievable all right Steve Moore thank
you and Charles Payne thank you hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else